[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Joe's in
Youngstown Ohio Hey Joe what's
up hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure um I am about $130,000 in debt um
on what and a lot of it is uh well the
majority is my truck and my wife's car
which is how much each um the truck is
40,000 and the wife's car is at ,000
okay so you're the problem
okay what else well that is
problem sorry I went straight to it go
ahead is only 30,000 a year right now
you said 30,000 what yes your income is
30k yes who and whose income is that is
that just one or one or the other or is
that both of you
combined that's just me uh my wife is a
stay home mom right now how many kids
three
okay what what's the rest of
130,000 okay so I own a home in uh PA
that I don't that I don't live at I have
it on land contract which was a mistake
you sold it on land contract cont or you
bought it on land contract I sold it on
land
contract okay so that one is still
15,000 on the mortgage and 20 28,000 on
the line of credit that was with that is
the payment coming in enough to cover
those two yes okay so that that's the
purpose of a land contract all right so
right now that's a break even it's not
your issue okay right that's 45 of the
130 right 90 so there's another 40
what's the other
40 uh a lot of it is I had a I was
self-employed for quite a few years and
so I made some mistakes with uh some job
estimations that I did and so I own owe
quite a few metal companies a lot of
money for metal like there's and how
long has it been since you paid
them uh it's been months okay is it
companies or company so you got 40K in
Vendor
debt yes there is actually
31,800 precisely in in okay building
materials there's another 8,000 floating
somewhere what is it um it is personal
loans from uh small lenders and stuff
for just what happened to your income
cuz you're used to
more I did um I quit my business because
I was going through a struggle for a
short period of time and I I decided
that I'm just going to quit go for a job
and it didn't work out so I started my I
started a new company later um two years
ago actually and I do right now I am
self-employed I do uh Commercial Roofing
and it's just my I have been struggling
more than I have ever struggled with a
business so um here's my thing and until
your business is making you enough money
to float your lifestyle it's really just
a hobby or a side hustle and I commend
you for starting that business but it's
not making enough money to to manage
your household bills obviously so you've
got to treat it like a side hustle
that's got to be something you're doing
on the side and building while you have
a full-time job what how much how long
you been doing that the the current
business two years yeah yeah okay Jade's
right I mean that thing should have been
pushed to the side as a side hustle
about 18 months ago or I I do also I
also work with another uh commercial
roofing company that I work for like
three two to three sometimes four days a
week I mean that's great but wouldn't
are you going to argue that 30,000 is
cutting fitting the bill right now
because it's not no absolutely not it's
not is the 30 from your business or the
30 is total of the two that's that's
total of the two yeah you're not making
enough uhhuh you used to make close to
six figures didn't you
I I have never made six figures I mean I
think the most I ever made was what
50,000 but okay there's two there's two
glaring things in your math that are
going on and part of what we do here is
we have the advantage of not being in
the forest so we can clearly see the
trees okay the glaring things are you
have two cars that you could never
afford at any time in your life they
should never have been purchased both of
them belong in the crazy column agre
nuts sell them both get two 1,002 $2,000
cars and then the second glaring area is
your income you've got to do some things
to get your income up shortterm and
longterm and I'd even be looking at the
wife staying at home I want to know how
young those kids are cuz it might be
that she can go out and get some work as
well cuz you worked your tail end off
yes when you guys were getting out like
crazy yeah so yeah in come is one side
of the equation and two cars in the cray
cray column is the other side of the
equation if you get those two things
fixed your life's going to shift very
quickly and the good to the good side
that's right